and this what I was thinking you know
Minh I thought if Joe Biden wins then
this whole country is gonna be is gonna
go so far woke so fast your head will
spin and no one will do anything about
it
what if Trump wins the insane woke
people will start some kind of civil war
I think that he'll try no no no listen
listen if Biden wins then all of these
conservatives and all of these people
who are complaining about the stuff will
sit on their hands and say oh well you
know I don't like it it'll do nothing
about it nothing will happen no you're
wrong because you already said earlier
when we were talking about what
California is doing when they come for
the elites children the elites will make
a difference and change and fight it
that's it and that's just the beginning
that was from James Lindsay who said I
think I saw the beginning of the end of
this I know but I think there's some
truth in that thing I do I do because
the people who make the most money they
like the status quo if they continue
making the most money because they can
pay for whatever security they need they
can pay to have food brought in for
bread wherever they want it it doesn't
affect them but when it starts affecting
them they're gonna be like okay we're
gonna make a difference I will agree
with you if they cancel Yale do you know
about that campaign yeah yeah if they
actually get Eli twiggy president Ella
who Gayle he was at one of the most
brutal slave traders maybe not the most
brutal but dude was brutal he passed the
law that every boat leaving Madras in
India had to carry at least ten slaves
for any reason Wow so it's like could
you it's like it's it's one thing to
have slavery it's another thing to be
like nope nope nope every boat it's like
but but Sir we're just a transport
buh-buh-buh-buh-buh ten slaves you're
transporting like we're literally just
like a couple fishermen Oh poop ten
slaves got to do it that's what that guy
was doing and he and he's Yale so a
bunch of conservatives have been like
cancel Yale will they roll any activist
you up to pull down Yale statue right
healy doubt it I doubt it exactly
because these people are off limits for
some reason the the privileged elites
are immune yeah exactly
so they will come for your football so
when will the hypocrisy reach them and
and make something click it's not you
know what men regular Americans might
vote for Trump this stuff might scare
them and I was thinking about it is
scary Nate we don't know that
I think it's according to the multiple
polls of support for black lives matter
is
like 28 points in the past month okay if
you--if we actually take the polls for
what they're worth
then Trump is down immensely and people
immensely support life as a matter who's
doing these polls a bunch of different
companies universities newspapers data
analytics firms and they all show a
similar trend and if enough if someone
had enough money they can pay to have
all these polls say whatever they want
no okay youyou I think so Rasmussen for
instance said Trump was underwater
resolutions favored chakram the entire
time okay like non-stop so there could
be one other factor here you follow Mike
Tsarevich and they'll fire you so how
many people are gonna say yes to a phone
call and who do you support not Paul Joe
Biden I think of course I mean I'm not a
big hit please please seriously please
that's what they're gonna say ah it's my
job I can't lose my job when someone's
asked they don't know who you are or
what you're calling for up.get Biden of
course yeah I do love black lives matter
you're absolutely right and they go and
cry in the corner and they're gonna go
pull a lever for Trump
that's that's what I think is way more
accurate but whatever any poll is saying
I agree i right Eirene however Hillary
Clinton lost because she was hated by
everybody like the hatred for her was
immense Trump was able to weaponize that
Joe Biden is sleepy
you know mumbly bumbly Joe he's a
freaking Preet Pete oh man sure but
understand how people can't stand him
because of all the creepy things that he
they've made him out to be a defenseless
pathetic old man that you you can't even
rag on him because he's just a
defenseless well you can rag on him but
it's sad it is not anger inducing yeah
so what if now the anti-trump sentiment
actually works and people learned their
mistake of 2016 by not voting as I
thought Hillary was gonna win and they'd
go and vote and Trump loses I then think
all of these culture war people in a
similar space to us will just sit back
and take all of it I don't think they'll
that's one way of seeing it I see a lot
of people going I am sick of riders and
them taking down statues of history that
has taught us what being a bad person
versus being a good person that shows us
we've learned from our history and
gotten to here so now you want to
destroy all that history and all these
people
I personally just talking about myself
I'm pissed
me too I don't I don't like it I I'm
voting for Trump I'm okay with it I'm
talking about it like I'll openly say it
like yeah I am I think he is doing a lot
of things that I didn't understand and I
didn't like him before but now over the
past 4 5 months how long would be doing
this show months 6 I am immersing myself
in what is going on in the world and I
see it I'm not an idiot
I'm a logical based person I follow the
logic I follow you know what's actually
happening and I think he's doing a lot
of things that we need to happen had
happen the Democrats have worked with
China it's like that scares me I am
frightened of China they clearly want to
control the world and I think that
there's a lot of people that they've
paid in America Democrats mostly that
are trying to undermine America as a
whole and it yeah because they got
foreign interests factories
international companies glamorous yes
the corporations that are making all the
profits from from all the movement of
all the product that we all use it's
like okay so if Trump wants to bring
that back to the States
no wonder he's been orange man bad for
the whole four or five years that he's
been in the media is pulling cash out of
their pockets bro yeah exactly Harris
hello yes yep it's like it's it's so
obvious to me now so it's like I'm
seeing it I'm like all right well I'm
not an idiot anymore and I I like to
believe that a lot of people my age that
are coming up like the coming of age of
coming out of being you know your bubble
to realizing what life is like it's like
the bell curve of life you're in your
mid-30s you know you're you know I'm
starting to yeah that's where you're
gonna be they call it being red pilled
sure yeah and I'm I wouldn't I would
never go back because I like wick I like
being informed like as soon as someone
opened the window you look outside you
said oh I'm votin Trump yeah yeah like
basically yeah I think it's funny that
you know people keep saying things like
who have they said that I'm one of the
slowest red pills ever you are no that's
but that's no they they are saying about
you I know but that's ridiculous it's
like the other people have made a better
point that I'm dish
red pills every day I just don't take my
own supply or whatever I'm like no no
you gotta understand man yeah but you
try to be an unbiased source of I mean
you are a little bit biased in certain
issues I try to be right I try to make
sure I have the facts straight before
giving my payment and that's that's
using logic right to find the truth and
so here's the issue of what's that's
legit that's why I respect you the issue
of what is red pill versus what is it I
mean for one people have different
definitions true but the set the sad
reality is right now all the red people
are at red pill folks you just happen to
be more right that's it I'm not I'm not
here to say I this tribe I'm here to say
well as the chips lie this tends to be
the correct path you know and during
Occupy Wall Street it was the other way
the the attacks on Occupy and the things
that people said about him was just
mostly a lot of it was BS and so I said
well actually no here's what happened
and then I ended up getting a lot of
like libertarian support and that's the
thing like the biggest group of like the
self-identifying group that follows my
content are libertarians mostly like
center-right libertarian yeah it's like
the biggest then it's like not I don't
know I think it's Trump supporters after
that then politically homeless like
moderate types yeah we did it we did it
we did a survey so anyway for the most
part I guess go back to the main point
is I agree with you that people are
angry and scared but will that be enough
to defeat the zombie hordes 65 million
voted for Hillary last time yeah when I
when I said there they're gonna come
into the they're gonna leave the cities
and start trying to run rampant and
they're gonna they're gonna reach
small-town America and and they're not
gonna like what they find they're gonna
be told to get out but they don't have
to go to small-town America why not if
they can control all cultural
institutions then there's nothing that
small-town America can do about anything
what are they gonna do keep their food
stop sending food around but why would
they why would they do that they need
stuff from the cities to like what do
they need from the cities well the
cities are like the the the intelligence
hubs for large manufacturing and major
corporations there's gonna be a huge
huge shift in America man and unless I
don't I don't know where it's gonna be
but it feels like it
you big trucks playing chicken screaming
at each other and ones Democrat ones
Republicans and slight what the left is
doing to be it's gonna be a crash
whatever happens the left doesn't need
to go to the rural areas so long as the
rural people keep bending the knee and
giving in to whatever the left says
there will not be a civil war that's why
I think if Trump wins the left will
incite it there and already trying to
incite everything right now sure and
look and there's no reason a difference
but listen there's no reason for the
Conservatives to go into New York stop
the riots you know so they just happen
right so if if Trump wins the left is
gonna go nuts and bring it to DC and
then you know there's gonna be hot
pocket areas where violence breaks out
worse than we've ever seen but if Biden
wins then the left will be emboldened if
tomorrow
AOC wins re-election the progressive
far-left cultists will be emboldened and
she's probably gonna win I think she
will we'll see though there's a lot of
good reasons suggest she might lose her
primary tomorrow - Michelle Caruso
Cabrera yeah I don't know we we weren't
able to see the discussion she had yeah
it made a OC banner the press from her
debate I wonder why these people listen
and no one has done anything you know so
I'm not talking I look I get it right
like what do you even do right Tom
cotton came out today and said the DOJ
must go after those who are tearing down
statues
I completely agree why did it take so
long where is everybody else
where's Rand Paul even has the first
thing if I saw someone men the first
thing the first day I saw Thomas
everything get torn down I was livid
when I made a video about it could you
imagine being a politician and being
like well they're tearing down Thomas
Jefferson anyway what do you guys want
for lunch
yeah I'd be free I'd be screaming I'd
get up and I would yell and point the
finger to each and every one of these
people out and I would say what are you
doing table yeah
time to flip some tables that's what
crowder was saying yeah reference to
Jesus yeah you asked you know che any
one of my friends who I would be voting
for this year they probably wouldn't
give us a Trump they would have no idea
that's flipping the table bro I'm
flipping the table man I don't like I
don't like it I took good analogy I
really do like it
you know the story like you
the temple the moneychangers are there
he's like what do you doing I don't know
I don't know they're just the full story
better rated a whip whoa wait whoa yeah
oh he took his time he braided a whip
and he flipped the tables and he chased
the money changers out of the temple he
was not messing around very peaceful man
we totally didn't get into super Jets
Wow what's nine fifty I know we got we
got serrated we got but we had a good
long conversation so I apologize for
everybody I do not apologize at all no
apologies everything that we've been
saying needs to be said it needs to be
talked about
people need to be having this kind of
conversation but I do want to with
everybody ideological based conversation
not a battlefield that's all it is
everyone wants to start battle so I
don't want to have a battle with you I'm
gonna talk to you I want to understand
your position they've done they don't
yes they want a battle that's what I'm
saying
they I want to have a battle I know so
exactly what I just said so don't say no
no no I'm saying yeah I want to have
conversation SP say yes no I do I want
to have conversations with people I want
for people right so don't tell me no
tell I'm not telling you now anyway
don't want to have conversation I'm
saying reviews people don't and there is
nothing you can do to make that I know
that you're right because that's what so
if you want to the extremes
yeah well I will never lose my optimism
I will never lose that part of me that
wants to help anyone and that's another
issue people people like you know what
you're a lost cause why should I even
bother I'll tell you why
because people see that and then it's
like you know what if he's gonna try
maybe I should try and then someone else
sees it you know what that's a good
point maybe I should try maybe I should
try to make a difference maybe I should
talk to those people what about the man
who went to who converted like a hundred
and two hundred people KKK members
what's his name Dale Davis Darrell Davis
right what a boss all he did if someone
said to that him those people don't want
to know what you're saying they you
can't change their mind if he said you
know what you're right I'm gonna quit
I'm not gonna go try and talk to them
and that he didn't do that
boom but he was like you know what I'm
gonna go talk to these people hey man
you want to go drive in that fancy car
and the guy was like what blew his mind
away that's actually
about making a connection Rypple they
need to realize that we're all the same
but that's actually a really strong
indictment of what the left is what that
Daryl Davis was able to actually go hang
out with Klan members yeah and if you go
to an anti folk group or you go to Chas
and they dragged a man through the
street in Chas yeah they dragged him
they choked him out that's freaky yeah
and my uncle got shot and killed by a
black person if does that mean I'm a
racist now because I I'm gonna equate
that to all black people everywhere no
I'm not gonna do that I think it's it's
it's very similar no I'm saying that
Darrell Davis went to Klan members right
I started talking to them right but
there's people in Chaz that will refuse
that right you're saying that well look
but there's people that will will drag
you through the streets and it's like
okay so that one person that's gonna
drag people through the streets that's
gonna that's gonna be the decide that
I'm gonna stop because that one person
is an a-hole no I'm saying if you went
try to talk to him you get the crap
beaten out of you well I'm not gonna go
to Chaz I have zero interest in going to
Chaz so then don't compare it to Darrell
Davis who did go and meet with Klan
members okay well I'm doing what I can
I'm here I have a for sure I have a show
I could talk about the the beliefs that
I had sure so so I'm doing it in my own
way so when it's said this is my
platform when the conversations tried to
happen in occupy over these very things
you know they did facilitators showed up
and started chanting and then everyone
started chanting and then not everything
shut down and that's a tactic they use
specifically to make sure the
conversations can't happen whether any
any good-natured people want to happen
or not so so I do believe there are a
lot of good people that you can talk to
because I think I've talked to my
friends about stuff I've explained them
things to them and they come around and
understand certain points but if you go
to these events and go to these meetings
they'll get physical there because look
man these people the people organizing
this stuff believe it or not are
well-read not the average person they're
they understand like rules for radicals
if they understand cult manipulation
techniques and they understand how you
by having these conversations are trying
to subvert them so they called Darrell
Davis a white supremacist quite
literally at the event I put on that's
crazy he tried to talk to them get this
he posted on
Facebook the man who was able to meet
with 200 Klansmen and he radicalize them
tried going over to his activist to talk
to him and I start screaming Nazi and
white supremacists at him and he posted
on Facebook what wasn't what the hell
was this yeah and this Facebook post got
like 30,000 shares of people being like
whoa yeah that's crazy the guy who could
dear addict lies the Klan couldn't even
have a conversation with these people
these are the people who are really
loudest because they are desperate for
attention they are desperate for a
connection they want to be a part of
something because they're not and a
majority of people are a part of
something already they they have their
their life that they're a part of so
when these people that are really saying
ah run you can't even question them you
can't talk to them you know when they
start coming to it to try to spread that
message they're gonna they're gonna meet
confidence they're gonna meet someone
who's confident and they're gonna be
like wow and that confident person is
gonna be like get out of my way
keep moving forward what do you mean
with that I'm talking about the majority
of Americans you keep you keep trying to
it almost feels like you're convinced
that these this minority of people it is
a minority it's a minority of a minority
uh no it's not even an 8% because you
it's less than that the people that are
actually like psycho crazy that can't be
changed
I'm it can't be 8% but those people that
you sure you can't change that but
there's 92 percent of the rest of us
that are like these people are crazy
we're gonna have a normal conversation
and move forward in life and then why
every calm every every single major
corporation bends the knee every single
video game bends the knee because they
want money they want the money they
don't want to lose and they're losing
money get what go broke is a meme
because they've burned down so often
yeah be a very fair moment they're
clueless they're clueless that's the
thing they they are so far away from the
average person that they have no idea
what's going on they're like oh I should
put up a rainbow flag because that means
we're not against the gays and it's like
what like what it if you didn't does
that mean you're against it and in
Oakland right they would smash your
window in if you didn't have
it's like man they're not they're not
getting money they're trying to save
their own their own lives so regular
people because we're not raising this
regular people who are not crazy are
getting on their knees and begging for
begging for safety and that's because
they're not having the kind of
conversations that we're having and
that's my point because when people
start having conversations like this not
battles conversations talking give me
your point I want your point of view
give me give me your point of view I'll
give you my point of view let's can
let's converse let's become stronger
from that that's lost but social media
we've been told for years you could be
anything you want shoot for the stars
you're you're special
you can do whatever you put your mind to
and it's like sure but you have to work
for it you aren't special
we're ants on this earth you gotta work
you gotta get up and do work if you want
to be anything these conversations have
been happening in circles like the
intellectual dark web okay
anin shows like Joe Rogan where the
biggest podcast in the world routinely
rap biggest podcast in the world is
completely unable to stop the rapid
transformation of society and the
destruction of our founding fathers and
our and and the general who defeated the
Confederates dude even though the Joe
Rogan podcast has been around for a
decade and he's hosted jordan peterson
and ben shapiro and the weinstein
brothers and dave rubin and Crowder and
we've had these conversations over and
over and over again every single
American who is not in that 8% fringe
gets on their knees and says please
leave me alone whenever someone comes to
them and threatens their job they will
not stand up for themselves that's what
I've been saying about what they need to
do people need to do something and the
first step is hiring your boss shut up
or I quit but they won't show a video
video games get made that are ridiculous
that have insane plots and insane
ideologies people complain about they
get called Nazis in the press yep and
the regular people know it's crazy
they're watching their cities burned
down and then what happens when they rip
down Thomas Jefferson nothing
you're right Democrats in New York City
are calling now for Thomas Jefferson to
be removed from the New York City
Council chamber and where are our
politicians where are the regular
Americans the silent majority to stand
up and say will
be silent no longer nowhere to be found
what are they gonna do they're gonna go
in the voting booth and say I'm gonna
pull the lever for Trump who in the past
four years has been unable to stop any
of this we've had a great economy a lot
of people made a lot of money and what's
happened it's been worse so here's what
I think's gonna happen if Joba if Trump
wins the left will go insane and burn it
all to the ground and regular people
will hide in their homes with their
newly found love of guns and they'll say
oh no what do we do and the left will
probably gain tons of ground and go
insane and people say please leave me
alone and if Joe Biden wins they'll take
over all our cultural institutions
they'll put psychotic and insane
definitions in our dictionary and they
will take over and regular Americans
will say please the love of God just
leave me alone and they never will
they'll never stop coming they will take
your job away they will come for your
parents you will you will do something
wrong they'll fire your mom they'll
they'll they'll come to your house with
fireworks and guns and Americans will
still just say please just leave me
alone and that's how it is even in the
Revolutionary War most people the
largest majority of people were
non-initiated
there was a small faction saying no
revolution there was a larger faction
saying revolution and the bulk said
please just leave me alone so long as
we've been going dealing with the
psychotic cancel culture and I've been
hearing about people like James James
Lindsey saying this and Coleman Hughes
saying I get messages all the time from
people saying this is insane and must
stop well where are you to stand up at
your job and tell your boss to shut up
when he says I'm gonna put out this
brand this bland brand message that
panders to these local unna ticks where
are you to say if you do that I quit
they say fine quit okay I will and I'll
go start my own company nowhere to be
found so we have these conversations and
what happens I'm under threat from being
banned every single day I just had a
video today labeled as hate speech and
when I asked him to overturn it they
said not this one you're on that you're
on you're on thin ice but don't worry
Tim you mostly play by the rules were
okay with what you say so how long until
they cut my channel off and they've been
doing it over and over again for the
past several years and no one is people
are nowhere to be found now of course
they go online and they'll post things
but then when it comes to their real
real life job when it comes to the woek
mob coming for them they just bend the
knee and they beg beg please please
local lunatics just don't hurt me and
I'll leave you alone
let you have whatever you want because I
don't care about the future for my
children I don't care about where this
country goes I don't care about all this
statute they've just destroyed and then
what happens the Republicans nowhere to
be found
you're absolutely no confidence in any
of these people to do anything I can sit
here all day and guess what
smack talked me all day and night say
Tim Poole all you do is complain about
things you're completely right but at
least I quit my job when I worked for
Disney and they said lie to the public I
said [ __ ] you and I told him cut my
contract off and they said no welcome to
the golden handcuffs Tim you got one
more year under lock and key and then I
said okay well I'm not gonna do what you
want and then finally it came to August
and I said buh-bye I'm gonna go do my
own thing and guess what it worked so
where the [ __ ] is everybody else know
where to [ __ ] be found
congratulations were demonetized I don't
give it a [ __ ] at this point no one is
doing anything in four years I've
routinely said you need to stand up for
yourself and tell these people to back
off and you won't do it maybe you guys
will but most people won't so there's
people on line complaining all day and
night okay walk away stop they won't do
it so why should I have any confidence
after a decade of this I'm willing to
walk away and go live in the woods when
all when all this just falls apart I
walked away from working with a Disney
company that was offering and pay me fat
cash if I just played ball and I said no
I won't do it and you know they did a
company that called me a white
supremacist the white people at this
company who are getting fat cash from
Disney called me the mixed race guy the
white supremacist and I didn't care I
said dude you don't man my worst case
scenario is I go and skate in mind my
own business why do you think so many
people want you to run want you to get
into office because it's people like you
who see the issue it's an even me like
we you and I we've had enough of these
conversations to be sick of these kind
of people I agree with everything you
said
you're absolutely right they should be
standing up and if you have an issue
with what's going on in our government
get into government take over the system
let's change the system you know it's
like I am gonna remain optimistic it's
just in my nature so but I agree I agree
with what you're saying you're right
people aren't standing up
I keep saying like well they're gonna
they're gonna finally hit those
Americans that are gonna you know show
them what's for yet but it's like but
you got a good point they're not
fighting these statues are being ripped
ripped down one day I showed up one guy
showed up and they attacked him and he
shot a person for it and so and that's
bad and I don't want that to happen I
don't want anyone to get shot I don't
want people to go out and engage in
physical conflict absolutely not
right now people need to stand up in
their schools in their jobs and say no
damn straight but they won't absolutely
why not because because I don't know
privilege because we're comfortable
because Society has left everyone
comfortable in in their comfortable
little world they don't understand what
we have anymore it's not cherished we
don't appreciate what we have it is the
norm and that's the issue
everyone thinks that this is just what
life is like this is what life is you
have a house you have a toilet you have
food at the store that's where the food
comes from the store is like no no no
it's society as a whole that's brought
us here and we've learned a lot in our
past and we have to use that to help us
get to the future and people aren't
having that conversation I think when
you look at the fact that the biggest
podcast in the world which just did this
massive hundred dollar you know a
hundred million dollar deal okay Joe
Rogan routinely calls these people out
rags on them yeah the fact that Donald
Trump won shows that there is a large
large group of people in this country
that are sick of this and I think it
also shows that as this stuff continues
to expand and encroach these are the
people who won't do anything about it so
you look at the fact that they ransacked
a bunch of major cities where a lot of
these people who hate the stuff live you
know you look at the fact that they flat
out said that they're going to put a man
in front the potential of for death row
because he did his job as an officer and
defended himself against someone who
stole his weapon it's crazy no one
protested for that no one's protesting
right now there a video was released
where they're like this is a disgrace
what happens when you have a guy in st.
Louis I don't know the exact story but
he was a it was an armed robbery he was
at a gun
and he engaged in a firefight the cops
cops killed him they rioted for it and
because of that they won and people then
started giving them what they wanted but
the rest of us will you know we don't do
this and for good reason i'm brian SAR
bad was not what we want but what i'm
saying is we've come to the point where
they've smashed all the windows they
said your churches are no longer allowed
they've welded the gates shut to jewish
playgrounds and they've spat in your
face and laughed the whole time and
still what do people do please just
leave me alone they're there they've
literally put a basin see it's there
clear bubble it's fear and it it's the I
just want to be left alone in my little
bubble I don't to lose my job
I just want to be comfortable I just
want to live my life that's what
everybody wants yep so I'm not confident
I'm not confident Trump was gonna win
and if the polls are accurate then maybe
what we believe in civil libertarian ISM
the things that we talked about Liberty
don't tread on me the right to freedom
of speech and expression you know it
they may be already dead you look at who
YouTube props up who makes it to these
big commercials you look at the fact
that Colin Kaepernick went through three
years of being a Nanette net negative
position sort of yeah but he said got a
Nike deal and now they're talking about
reciting him he won he's gonna win in
the end
his whole his whole shtick for
manipulation and for four bucks is gonna
work out work out for him you look at
all these these these video game
companies and they've just kept pushing
through no matter how much people said
this is wack and I don't like it they're
like we don't care what you like and we
don't care if we burn out and make no
money so get what go broke is not a law
but it is a tendency and so you look at
these companies that are willing to lose
money and just keep doing it and then
eventually they'll be right I guess but
the people who are demanding it don't
have money and then it ends up just
happening and so the the you know when
you look at the Last of Us - you have a
narrative which does not reflect the
majority of how people view the world
sure but so long as they keep smashing
this in your face eventually you just
give up and say fine please I'll take
whatever you make me take and so there
it is they're gonna ban hate speech
they're gonna right now California is
going to repeal the
they voted to repeal the civil rights
provision from their constitution how
much longer will our understanding of
the First Amendment exist the right to
free speech how long until they rule
while hate speech actually isn't because
the UN already said so and Europe parity
said so so how long till in the US when
they say the Supreme Court rules
what happens if Biden wins and they put
on a bunch of liberal justices who then
rule free speech does not include
derogatory statements made about someone
based on their protected status and then
free speeches is void because everything
is offensive right well then if it
happens I'll tell you what I'm gonna go
live in a van down by the river I guess
but at least I quit my job I refuse to
stand for it I don't I don't think
there's a position where I can go out
and protest or anything yeah but I made
it my point to constantly talk about
these issues as they get worse and and
to tell people how bad it's getting but
when when I work for this company and
they told me to lie I said no and they
were like well you have to us you can
cut my Condren off right now and they're
like well how about we talk about it in
a few months and then they literally
just had me do nothing so we were trying
to do this show you know and when I was
working for it you know supposed to be
working for different company yeah
because we met the CEO he was all about
it he was like yeah you didn't want this
conversation to happen now no he was
like well our audience is progressive so
we want to side with them whatever they
want and that's and that's where that's
where you end up he was wrong by the way
the company went up in flames thanks for
checking out this clip from the Tim cast
IRL podcast we do the show live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 p.m. if you want
to catch the full show tune into this
channel subscribe hit the like button or
check us out on iTunes and Spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you